ladies and gentlemen the forty fifth and
final President of the United States
[Applause]
unbelievable
move it's great to be back in America
how very much I've loved you how very
much I've tried my best to give you a
good life it's it hot in here or did I
just pull out of the Paris Accord
nothing god what a terrible deal that
was for America everyone says Trump
Trump what about the melting ice cups
don't worry my environmental policy will
take care of the Penguins the Pittsburgh
Penguins a tremendous hockey team the
bird penguins can get incredible jobs as
coal miners but all the scientific
studies indicated oh who cares about
science that's Bernhard's I'm fighting
for the forgotten man he doesn't read
studies he's the man who forgot to read
and that's my base my base which is
loyal to me this is why the theme of
tonight's show is loyalty I surrounded
myself with the most loyal people except
the one guy who is leaking everything
that's said in every White House needed
you can said that you might fire several
members of your staff in the coming week
is that what you call loyalty of course
loyalty is a two-way street it's
something you do for me but it's also
something I do for me my staff knows
that I have their back because that's
the best place to stab them I'm the
president can you come see see it what's
wrong